اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير ساعه جديده على
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
نبداها دائما بالعناوين
تركيا تفتتح صناديق الاقتراع وسط اجراءات
امنيه مشدده ثلاثه مرشحين للرئاسه واربعه
وعشرون حزبا للبرلمان
اشتباكات في نابلس بعد ساعات على دخول
الهدنه في غزه حيز التنفيذ واسرائيل تعيد
فتح المعابر تدريجيا
مع استئناف محادثات جده لبحث ايصال
المساعدات الاشتباكات تتجدد في الخرطوم
وسط تحليق مكثف للمقاتلات
لاول مره منذ الحرب في برلين والمانيا
تستبق الزياره بحزمه مساعدات بثلاثه
مليارات دولار
تركيا على موعد مصيري وحافل انتخابات
رئاسيه وبرلمانيه حاسمه انتخابات الرئاسه
يتنافس عليها ثلاثه مرشحين وهم مرشحوا
تحالف الشعب الرئيس الحليب رجب طيب
اردوغان ومرشح تحالف الامه كمال كلجدار
اوغلو ومرشحوا تحالف الاجداد سنان اوغن
مراكز الاقتراع فتحت ابوابها في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه هذا
الصباح وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده وبلغ عدد
الناخبين المسجلين اكثر من 64 مليون ناخب
كما تم وضع ما يقارب
192 الف صندوق اقتراع في البلاد وخارجهم
اما الصراع الرئيسي مشاهدينا وفق التوقعات
سوف يكون بين اردوغان وكليجدار اوغلو اذ
تظهر استطلاعات الراي تقدما بفا رق ضئيل
لكمال كيلجار اوغلو المنافس الرئيسي
لاردوغان الرئيس الحالي فيما تشهد المدن
الرئيسيه تعزيزات امنيه حتى يتمكن
الناخبون من ممارسه حقهم في التصويت بامان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي ولايه هاتاي المنكوبه بالزلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا قبل اشهر انطلقت عمليه التصويت
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه حيث شهدت المراكز
الانتخابيه اقبال العشرات من الناخبين
القادمين من ولايات اخرى مجاوره الى مراكز
الاقتراع حيث نزح الاهالي من مناطقهم منذ
ثلاثه اشهر بعد انهيار منازلهم بفعل
الزلزال وتجري عمليه التصويت وسط اجراءات
امنيه مشدده
وشبكه مراسله العربيه من تركيا تنضم الي
من انقره منفذه العربيه فاطمه فهد من
كهرمان مرعش موفد العربيه غسان ابو اللوز
ومن اسطنبول ينضم الينا ايضا وفد العربيه
طاهر بركه اهلا بكم معي اهلا بكم جميعا
معي في هذه النشره ابدا معك فاطمه كيف هي
نسب
اقبال لديك في هذا المركز لماذا تتواجدين
في هذا المركز ايضا تحديدا
نسب الاقبال جنونيه وكبيره بشكل رهيب يعني
لدرجه اننا لا نتمكن حتى من المشي داخل
المركز بعد هذه اللحظات الاقوال جدا كبير
انا الان اتواجد في الغرفه التي سيدني بها
صوته الوضع قليلا متوتر هنا دخلنا الى هذه
الغرفه بشق الانفس انتشار امني مكثف وكبير
حول المركز بطبيعه الحال هذه الغرفه في
مدرسه ارجنتين الابتدائيه هي المدرسه التي
درس فيها والتي سياتي للتصويت فيها كذلك
يعني تواجد صحفي كبير ومكثف للصحافه
الاجنبيه وللصحافه التركيه كذلك قبل قليل
رئيس الهيئه العليا للانتخابات احمد ينار
رئيس الهيئه العليا للانتخابات احمد دينار
كان هنا ليدلي بصوته بالفعل قام بالادلاء
بصوته وخرج بتصريحات قال فيها بانه يجب
عدم شطب اي مرشح رئاسي في ورقه التصويت
وهم اصدروا تحذيرات وتعليمات لازمه بهذا
الخصوص واضاف احمد دينار رئيس الهيئه
العليا للانتخابات نايف بان عمليه التصويت
تستمر حتى الان من دون اي عوائق وانهم
يتابعون بشكل مستمر وكثيف نظام ابلاغ فوري
مع الفرق لاي طارئ كان اذا هذه الغرفه
التي سيدخل اليها بعد دقائق قليله وسنكون
معكم تباعا لتغطيه ذلك وسيقوم بادلاء
صوتهم الحضور هنا مختلف ومتنوع وكبير جدا
هناك كبار السن الذين يتركزون على العكاز
لياتون هنا لهنا للادلاء باصواتهم هناك
الشباب والشابات وهناك ايضا
والفتيان الذين ياتون للادلاء بصوتهم
معظمهم يدلون باصواتهم في هذا المركز
تحديدا لكليشجار اوغلو لان هي المنطقه هنا
معروفه بتاييدها للمعارضه اعداد الناخبين
المسجلين في هذا المركز سبعه الاف ناخب
يوجد 18 صندوق انتخابي في هذا المركز وكل
صندوق يعني يستقبل قرابه 360 الى 380
ناخبا تقريبا نايف الظاهر النسب الاقبال
ايضا في اسطنبول هل يمكن ان يعني تكون
نسب مقاربه على الاقل لما يحدث في انقره
هذه الكثافه التي رايناها من خلف الزميله
فاطمه فهد اما الوضع يختلف
لا يختلف ابدا بالعكس الاقبال كثيف جدا
وكنا رصدنا ذلك منذ ساعات ولحظات افتتاح
الصناديق الاولى في القسم الاوروبي من
اسطنبول ومن ثم انتقلنا الى القسم الاسيوي
الى اوسكودار حيث سيصوت بعد قليل الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان احد المرشحين الرئيسيين
لهذه المعركه الانتخابيه هو ضد
يعني اتحدث عن المرشحين الرئيسيين فقط هنا
واضافه الى الانتخاب في الاقتراعات
البرلمانيه كذلك هناك كثافه في التصويت
بدون شك تشهد هذه الانتخابات سليمان سويلم
الذي يدلي بصوته في ولايه اسطنبول ايضا في
الانتخابات بمنطقه غازي عثمان باشا بولايه
اسطنبول قال قبل قليل انه نسب الاقتراع
فاقت نظيرتها في الانتخابات الماضيه اذا
هذه تاكيدات ايضا من وزاره الداخليه التي
نشرت 600 الف عنصر لحمايه هذه الانتخابات
حتى انتهائها عند الساعه الخامسه مساء
بتوقيت المحلي
اكمل بعدها الصمت الانتخابي حتى يبدا
الفارس فارس الاصوات ومن ثم نبدا بالتعرف
على نتائج اولا باول ساكون معكم طيله هذا
اليوم ايضا مساء من مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه في اسطنبول الاكبرتي كما يعرف
هنا لاطلاعكم على النتائج اذا الصوره عند
فاطمه مع
اوغلو المرشح المعارضه والصوره من عندي
هنا في اسطنبول مع انتظار رجب طيب اردوغان
الرئيس الحالي لياتي ولكي يدلي بصوته
الاعلام الدولي والعالمي المحلي الاقليمي
كلهم كلهم منتشر بقوه كبيره وسيارات
الاسعاف الاجهزه الامنيه كلهم ينتشرون
لتامين يوم هذا الانتخابات مع المراقبين
الدوليين المتواجدين في مراكز الاقتراع
والمراقبين الحزبيين اولئك الذين منعهم
من التدخين يوم الاقتراع ومن تناول الطعام
قائلا انهم لا يمكنكم ان تذهبوا للتدخين
وتناول الطعام بحجه ذلك وتترك صناديق
الاقتراع الى هنا وصلت هذه المعركه في هذه
الانتخابات نايف هذا هو المشهد من اسكودار
حيث لازلنا ننتظر منذ يعني اكثر من ساعتين
وصول الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لكي يدلي
بصوته وسنكون معكم اول باول لحظه وصوله
لكي ننقل لكم الصوره واذا كان سيدلي باي
تصريح حول يعني ما يسال عنه من قبل
الصحفيين الذين يتجمهرون هنا الصوره ايضا
سنتابع كذلك من مكان اخر طاهر مع الزميل
غسان ابو اللوز من كرمان مرعش مركز
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا خلال الاشهر
الماضيه غسان كيف تبدو صوره الاجواء
الانتخابيه في كهرمان مرعش حتى هذه اللحظه
لديك كيف يمكن تقييم نسب الاقبال ايضا
نعم بالفعل نايف الصوره هنا في كهرمان
مرعش وفي الولايات الجنوبيه التي ضربها
الزلزال تقاس على مقياس ريختر بالنسبه
للانتخابات في هذه المنطقه كما تعلم
الزلزال الكارثي الذي ضرب البلاد في هذه
الولايات قبل اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر كان ماده
دسمه وارضيه خصبه لسواء كان الرئيس
اردوغان وحزب العداله والتنميه او
المعارضه بزعامه كلجدار اوغلو المرشح
للرئاسه وبالتالي كان هناك حاله استقطاب
كبير واستثمار لهذا الزلزال من كل جهه من
كل جانب من كل طرف لاستماله الناخبين في
هذه الولايات تاريخيا نايف هذه الولايه
كهرمان مرعش واغلب الولايات الجنوبيه تصوت
لحزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس اردوغان
حتى اللحظه نحن منذ ثلاث ساعات نقف عند
هذا المركز الاختراع الثاني الذي نزوره
اليوم وقمنا باستطلاع العديد من الاراء
للناخبين الذين ادلب باصواتهم هناك هناك
تفاوت في الا حول الاشخاص او المرشحين
الذين
صوتوا لهم هناك من يقول بانه مستمر في
التصويت للرئيس اردوغان وحزب العداله
وتنميه هناك من يقول بانه لا يريد حزب
العداله والتنميه ولا الرئيس اردوغان 20
عاما كافيه من هذا الحكم وايضا هناك من
يريد وجوه جديده ومستقبل افضل للبلاد
وبالتالي حتى هذه اللحظه الصوره يعني لا
تبدو واضحا ننتظر بطبيعه الحال النتائج
الاوليه بعد الساعه الخامسه من هذا اليوم
هنا في كهرمان اكثر من 750 الف نايف يحق
لهم الانتخاب وطبيعي في هذه الولايه ايضا
كما ذكرت بانها تاريخيا تصور تصوت للرئيس
اردوغان ولحزب العداله والتنميه نعم غسان
انا فقط اشكر الزميله فاطمه فهد من انقره
موفده العربيه على هذه الصوره والمعلومات
التي نقلتها الينا ابقى معكما مع الزميل
طاهر بركه ايضا طاهر يعني ربما ياتي
السؤال عن الدلالات التي اراد المرشحان
الرئيسيان في هذه الانتخابات تتحدث عن
الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وكذلك ايضا زعيم
المعارضه ايصال
الدلالات للناخبين في تركيا كيف يمكن
الحديث عنها
صحيح نايف كان هناك دلالات واضحه في
اختيار الامكنه التي يختفي منها
حملتيهما الانتخابيتين نحن نتحدث هنا عن
اختيار الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان مسجد ايه
صوفيا الذي حوله الى مسجد لكي يختم هذه
الحمله الانتخابيه
في صلاه المغرب تحديدا وكذلك على المقلب
الاخر نتحدث عن كليتش دار اوبلو الذي
تابعنا مع الزميل فاطمه بالامس كيف اختتم
حملته الانتخابيه عند ضريح مصطفى كمال
اتاتورك وهنا نتحدث عن توجهين مختلفين لا
يعني ان الرئيس لا يعترف بالتوجه الى تركي
بالعكس ويذكره كمؤسس ويذكره دائما في سله
الرؤساء الذين يذكرهم بالخير ويشير اليهم
باصبع اليد دائما على تاريخهم الذي خدم
تركيا مصطفى كمال اتاتورك
وهذه نقطه مهمه ايضا يلمح اليها دائما بل
يصرح بها الرئيس اردوغان دائما
تركت اوزال اضافه الى نجم الدين اربكان
الاب الروحي للتيارات الاسلاميه التي
انبثق من رحمها حزب العداله والتنميه
بزعامه رجب طيب اردوغان اذا العامل
العلماني الاتاتوركي واضح كان في ختام
حمله في كل حمله وفي ختام حمله وهذا له
دلاله اما العامل الديني الاسلامي المحافظ
من خلال مسجد ايه صوفيا الذي حول الى مسجد
فهو يبين العامل المحافظ الذي يجتذب من
خلاله اردوغان قاعدته الدينيه المحافظه
تخيل سالت سائق تاكسي عند بعد قدومه الى
هنا لماذا مع من انت قال انا ساصوت
لاردوغان فقلت لماذا ليس الطرف الاخر
لاحظ العامل الديني كما هو مهم عند فئه لا
باس بها من المجتمع التركي غير
فئه تلك الفئه غير العلمانيه قال لي انك
داس بحذائه على سجاده صلاه سالت عن ذلك
واستقصيت وعرفت بانه المعارضه ترفض مثل
هذا الكلام
يرفض وحزب الشعب الجمهوري ويقولون بانه
كان خطا محضا لم ينتبه الى ذلك ولكن حزب
العداله والتنميه دائما ما ياخذ هذا على
الطرف الاخر على انه زله العامل الديني
ايضا اين هو مهم في موضوع حزب الشعب
الجمهوري الذي يقول بعض قياداته لا تقول
اننا نحن فقط لعلمانيون والبراليون ولا
علاقه لنا بالدين نحن ايضا ابناء عائلات
محافظه نحن ايضا قيادات لدينا تمسك بالقيم
والتقاليد والعادات
بالدين الاسلامي لانه هذا ما يجمعنا ولا
مشكله لنا فيه نحن نحافظ فقط على قيم
الجمهوريه التركيه العلمانيه التي تركيا
التي اسسها مصطفى كمال اتاتورك في نقطه
عدنان مدارس التي قلت لك انها مهمه ايضا
دورا لماذا لانه في عام 1950 في نفس هذا
اليوم في 14 مايو قامت الانتخابات
الديمقراطيه الاولى قادها الحزب
الديمقراطي بزعامه عدنان مندارس وفاز بها
حتى
الفكم عندما تم الانقلاب عليه واعدم مع
اثنين من ابرز قاده حكومته وزير الخارجيه
فطين رشدي ووزير الماليه واما محمود جلال
بيار الرئيس في سجن مدى الحياه لكبر سنه
لماذا عدنان مدارس يذكره دائما رجب طيب
اردوغان لانه تتهمه المعارضه والسابقه
وحزب الشعب الجمهوري سابقا بانه انفتح على
الطبقه الفلاحيه الدينيه وهدد قيم التركيه
العلمانيه التي قامت عليها اسس الجمهوريه
التركيه اما التوجه الديني المحافظ للرئيس
اردوغان فيجعله دائما ما ينجذب الى تلك
المرحله والى عدنان مندارس الذي يعني
يصفونه هنا الفئه المحافظه طبعا بشهيد
الاذان لانه اعاد الاذان باللغه العربيه
الى التركيه غسان الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
ومركزه كان كرما مرعش كيف القى بظلاله على
الناخبين على اختيارات الناخبين ايضا كذلك
في كهرمان عشر سنه
المواقف نايف تتباين بخصوص هذا الموضوع
هناك من يرى بان هذه كارثه طبيعيه لا يد
للحكومه والسلطات التركيه بما جرى وترى
بان السلطات التركيه قامت بواجبها على
اكمل وجه في هذه الكارثه وقدمت اقصى ما
يمكن ان تقدمه وما زالت تواصل عملياتها
التي بداتها منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر حين
وقع هذا الزلزال وهناك من يلوم الحكومه
وسلطات بانها كانت مقصره خلال الساعات
والايام الاولى في التعامل وسرعه التجاوب
مع الزلزال الذي ضرب 11 ولايه في جنوب
البلاد وبالتالي هو يلقي بظلاله على هذه
المناطق وهذه الولايات خصوصا بعد مرور
ثلاثه اشهر من هذه الكارثه ويعني بما
يعتبرونه او يصفونه بطء في تعامل السلطات
مع هذه الكارثه لكن رجب طيب اردوغان كان
كان قد وعد في السابق بان الحكومه ستوفر
منازل جاهزه وستبني هذه المنازل خلال عام
وستقدم هذه المنازل خلال عام نتحدث عن
اكثر من 500 كيلو مربع مساحه المساحه التي
ضربها الزلزال وهي مساحه كبيره جدا وواسعه
جدا وبالتالي تحتاج الى هذا الوقت لا زالت
عمليات ازاله بعض الانقاذ المتبقيه مثلا
على سبيل المثال في كهرمان مرعش حيث قمت
بجوله في المنطقه وايضا هناك تعامل مع
البنايات الاله للسقوط وايضا هناك خيام ما
زالت موجوده ومنتشره وبجود جاهزه ما زالت
موجوده ومنتشره وبالتالي المواطن التركي
والناخب التركي يامل الان بان يتحسن وضعه
وحاله الى افضل وبه اسرع وقت لكن العمل ما
زال متواصل ومتواصل حتى هذه اللحظه
اردوغان كما اشرنا انه يعني قدم وعوده وما
زالت العمليات متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه لكن
هناك من لا يثق بالحكومه الحاليه والحزب
الحاكم وايضا هناك من يتمسك بحزب الحزب
الحاكم
قبل قليل قبل قليل سبعيني سالناه لمن صوت
قال طبعا انا صوت لي رجب طيب اردوغان انا
اصوت منذ سبعينيات القرن الماضي وبالتالي
لم اجد يعني
المس الفرق فيما قدمته السلطات السابقه
سوى على يد حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس
اردوغان وبالتالي هناك فروقات وهناك ما
قدمه اردوغان للبلاد وبالتالي انا سابقى
اصوت لاخر يوم في حياتي للرئيس اردوغان
وبالتالي وايضا على الطرف الاخر هناك من
يرفض التصويت لاردوغان وليس ايضا نايف
موضوع الزلزال هناك ايضا الظروف
الاقتصاديه والوضع الاقتصادي الذي تمر به
البلاد هناك تضخم هناك للانهيار لليره
وهناك ارتفاع للاسعار هناك من يقول بان
هذا الوضع هو على العالم كله وهناك من
يقول بانه لا لا هذا وضع تسبب به الرئيس
اردوغان وبالتالي يجب ان نقوم بتغيير
الرئيس ونقوم بتغيير حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم ويجب ان يكون هناك تغيير بعد 20
عام للحزب الحاكم من الحكم في السلطه
وبالتالي هي يعني وجهات النظر والاراء
متفاوته ومختلفه فيما بينها نعم اشكركما
جزيل الشكر من كهرمان مرعش موفد العربيه
غسان ابو اللوز ومن اسطنبول ايضا موفد
العربيه طاهر بركه شكرا جزيلا لكم
اذا ثلاثه مرشحين يخوضون سباق الرئاسه
التركيه رجب طيب اردوغان كما كالجدار
اوغلو وسنان اوغن نتعرف او نتعرف الان على
نبذه عن كل منهم
[موسيقى]
استلم ضفه السلطه منذ عام 2003 اول رئيس
منتخب مباشره عام 2014
شهدت فتره حكمه محاوله انقلاب فاشله عام
تمكن حزبه من الفوز باستفتاء عام 2017
وفرض تعديلات دستوريه
تحولت تركيا في عهده من النظام البرلماني
للرئاسي
حكم عقدين ويسعى لولايه رئاسيه ثالثه قد
تم وعودا اقتصاديه عده تستهدف الشباب
والتضخم
[موسيقى]
خطا اول خطواته السياسيه عام 2002
بانضمامه لحزب الشعب الجمهوري انتخب رئيسا
للحزب عام 2010
وصف بمهندس التحالفات منذ عام 2014
تصدر وجه المعارضه على مدى عقد عرف بلهجه
انتقاضيه حاده تجاه اردوغان والحزب الحاكم
وعد بتحسين الاقتصاد ورفع مستوى الحريات
واعاده النظام البرلماني
يدخل سباق الانتخابات الرئاسيه للمره
الاولى ويعد اصغر مرشح مرشح عن تحالف
الاجداد الذي يضم اربعه احزاب تعرف
بمواقفها القوميه
عضو سابق في حزب الحركه القوميه طرد منها
عام 2017 لكنه ظل مخلصا له
اشتهر بخطابه العنصري ضد اللاجئين من ابرز
وعوده الرئاسيه اعاده المهاجرين الى
بلادهم الغاء نظام الرئاسي العوده للنظام
البرلماني
وهذه نافذه على بعض ابرز الاحزاب
المتنافسه في الانتخابات البرلمانيه
التركيه نتابع
الاحزاب السياسيه في تركيا
حزب العداله والتنميه حزب اسلامي محافظ
يتراسه رجب طيب اردوغان
لديه 295 نائبا بالبرلمان هو الحزب الحاكم
منذ 2002
[موسيقى]
تشكل من قبل نواب منشقين عن حزب الفضيله
الاحزاب السياسيه في تركيا
حزب الشعب الجمهوري حزب علماني يتراسه
كمال كالجدار اوغلو
[موسيقى]
لديه 146 نائبا بالبرلمان هو اقدم حزب
سياسي تاسس عام 1919
اكبر الاحزاب المعارضه للحزب الحاكم
الاحزاب السياسيه في تركيا
حزب الحركه القوميه حزب قومي يؤمن بتعزيز
الهويه الوطنيه
يعتبر الب ارسلان تركيش قائد الفكره
القوميه
يتراسه دوله بهتشري لديه تسعه واربعون
نائبا بالبرلمان
[موسيقى]
الحزب الشريك الاكبر في الائتلاف الحاكم
ناشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
بعد تصريحاته التحريضيه الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه تطالب الجنائيه الدوليه
باعتقال بنكفير
حياكم الله من جديد خمسه ايام عنيفه من
التصعيد في غزه تلاها هدوء حذر في القطاع
فقد دخلت اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار بين
اسرائيل وحركه الجهاد حيز التنفيذ برعايه
مصريه هدنه انهت قصفا خلف ثلاثه 33 قتيلا
ونحو 190 جريحا بين الفلسطينيين الهدره
نصت على وقف استهداف المدنيين والمنازل
والافراد الا في حاله خاصه اي حين يكون
لدى اسرائيل معلومات موثوقه وخطيره وفق
بياني رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي فان الهدوء
سيقابل بالهدوء ولكن تعرض تل ابيب لاي
تهديد او هجوم يعني ان اسرائيل ستواصل
الدفاع عن نفسها على حد تعبير وبسبب هذه
الهدنه اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي فتح معبري
بيت حانون وكرم ابو سالم كريم شالوم في
قطاع غزه بصوره جزئيه
وتدريجيه واشارت مصادر الى انه سيتم ادخال
وقود الى القطاع ومساعدات انسانيه خلال
الساعات المقبله وان الامر متوقف على مدى
الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
هذا ورحب البيت الابيض باعلان وقف اطلاق
نار في غزه مشيدا بالحكومه المصريه
لتوسطها في الاتفاق وقالت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض ان المسؤولين الامريكيين
عملوا عن كثب مع شركاء الاقليمين للتوصل
الى هذا الحل للاعمال القتاليه من اجل منع
سقوط المزيد من الخسائر في الارواح واعاده
الهدوء الى الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
اعلى حد سواء
من حدود قطاع غزه تنظم الينا مراسله
العربيه لانك الغاسلين مرحبا بك معي في
هذه النشره كيف انعكست هذه الهدنه على
الارض من من امامك ايضا في حدود قطاع
غزلان
اهلا بك نايف فعليا هدوء يسود قطاع غزه
وايضا مستوطنات الغلاف يعني منذ يعني
الاعلان عن الاتفاقيه ليله امس كان هناك
فقط اختراق واحد من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي
وايضا من قبل الجانب الفلسطيني ولكن منذ
ليله امس حتى صباح اليوم بعد هذا الاختراق
لم يكن هناك اي اختراق اخر اين تحدث عن
هدوء يسود المنطقه لساعات طويله حتى كان
هناك اجراءات في مستوطنات الغلاف نحن
حاليا متواجدين بمستوطنه تناحل عاوز نبحث
وهو لا انا ساعود اليك اذا اذا
اذنتي الان نشاهد دخول
المرشح المعارضه ايضا كمال
اوكلو والذي يدلي بصوته في احدى لجان
العاصمه التركيه انقره في هذا اليوم
الانتخابي الذي تعيشه تركيا بعد ان فتحت
الصناديق الاقتراع ابوابها منذ صباح هذا
اليوم اذا المرشح الرئاسي كما نشاهد
امامنا كمال
يدلي بصوته في احدى لجان انقره كما نتابع
واياكم في هذه الصور
المباشره امامنا من العاصمه التركيه انقره
واخذ ايضا كذلك هذه الصور
لادلائه بصوته ايضا في احدى لجان العاصمه
التركيه انقره مرشح تحالف الامه كمال
كلجدار اوغلو دخل اذن الى هذا المركز والى
احدى لجان العاصمه التركيه انقره ويدلي
بصوته الان كما نشاهد من خلف الستار في
هذه الصوره امامنا اذا في هذا اليوم
الانتخابي التركي المرشح الرئاسي كمال
اوغلو يدلي الان بصوته في احدى لجان
العاصمه التركيه انقره النسب الاستطلاع
كما تابعنا واياكم خلال الايام
الماضيه اشارت في اكثر من مكان الى ان
كمال
أوجلو يتقدم ولو بنسبه طفيفه على منافسه
في هذه الانتخابات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اذن نتابع هذه الصور كما ذكرنا
واياكم للمرشح الرئاسي كمال كلجدار اوكلو
يدلي بصوته في احدى لجان انكر وطبعا هو
المرشح الاول من المرشحين الرئاسيين
الثلاثه الذي يدلي بصوته هذا الصباح في
العاصمه التركيه انقره كما نشاهد اهتمام
واسع اذا من وسائل الاعلام بهذه اللجنه
تحديدا التي يتواجد فيها كمال كريجدار
اوكلو ايضا كذلك بصوته الزميله فاطمه فهد
كانت تتواجد في ذات اللجنه منذ الصباح
تحدثت عن اقبال كثيف عن فئات عمريه مختلفه
ايضا وصلت الى هذه اللجنه والى اكثر من
لجنه ايضا كذلك في العاصمه التركيه انقره
للادلاء باصواتهم خرج الان بعد ان ادلى
بصوته اذا في احدى لجان انقره كان كمال
اوغلو قد وعد
بتحسين الاوضاع الاقتصاديه رفع مستوى
الحريات ايضا كذلك واعاده النظام
البرلماني ايضا الى تركيا
كان قد وصف بانه مهندس التحالفات ايضا
كذلك وهو كما نعلم زعيم تحالف الامه وهو
وجه المعارضه ايضا كذلك الذي يعني يوصف
بانه الوجه الاقوى في المعارضه منذ عشره
اعوام حتى اليوم يدخل هذه الانتخابات وهذا
السباق الرئاسي كذلك ايضا في تركيا الى
جانب كذلك
المرشح اخر الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
مرشح تحالف الشعب وكذلك ايضا مرشح تحالف
الاجداد السنان اوغان اذا مراكز الاقتراع
كانت قد فتحت ابوابها ابوابها في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه ايضا حتى
كذلك وسط
امنيه وكذلك مشدده
وعدد الناخبين ايضا بلغوا ربما اكثر من 64
مليون ناخب المسجلين طبعا في هذه
الانتخابات الان يغادر المرشح الرئاسي
التركي كمال كالجدار اوغلو بعد ان ادلى
بصوته في احدى لجان العاصمه التركيه انقره
وكما ذكرنا قبل قليل كانت يعني وعوده
الانتخابيه ربما عناوين عريضه
لبرمجه الانتخابي بتحسين الاقتصاد برفع
ايضا كذلك
الحريات في تركيا وباعاده النظام
البرلماني ايضا كذلك الى تركيا هو يعتبر
وجه المعارضه الابرز ربما منذ عشره اعوام
يدخل هذا السباق الرئاسي
وكما اشارت استطلاعات الراي بانه تفوق
باكثر مما كان وفي اكثر من استطلاع على
منافسه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
اعود مره اخرى الى حدود قطاع غزه من هناك
مراسله العربيه لنا كالغاسي لانا كنت قد
سالتك قبل قليل عن مدى التزام الاطراف
بهذه الهدنه بوقف اطلاق النار ايضا كذلك
التبلور هذا على الارض امام كيف الحدود
اهلا بك فعليا كما تحدثت نحن الان نتواجد
في مستوطنه نحل عوز وهي ايضا من
المستوطنات القريبه من الحدود التي تم
قصفها بشكل يومي من قبل الصواريخ التي
اطلقت من قطاع غزه ولكن منذ مساء اليوم
بعد منذ مساء امس عفوا بعد تم الموافقه
على اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق النار كان هناك فقط
يعني اختراق واحد بالامس من قبل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وايضا من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه التي قصفت عده مناطق ولكن منذ
مساء الامس بعد هذا هذه الرشقه الاخيره
حتى صباح اليوم لم يكن هناك اي يعني رشقات
صاروخيه اطلقت اي ان الهدوء يعود على ما
يبدو الى قطاع غزه وايضا الى مستوطنات
الغلاف كان هناك ايضا اجراءات من قبل
السلطه او السلطات الاسرائيليه الداخليه
التي يعني اعلنت اولا بفتح فعليا
المعابر الحدوديه اي هناك معبران معبر
تجاري شمال القطاع وايضا معبر جنوبي يعني
للافراد يسمح للفلسطينيين بالدخول للعلاج
او حتى العمال فعليا من قطاع غزه للعمل في
اسرائيل ولكن يعني ما زال هناك تجديدات
هناك ايضا حصار على قطاع غزه منذ سنوات اي
ان يعني الفلسطينيين بصعوبه جدا يخرجون من
قطاع غزه ولكن على ما يبدو ايضا منذ صباح
اليوم كان هناك ازاله للحواجز من
المستوطنات الغلاف وايضا فتح اعداد كبيره
من المتاجر المدارس في معظم المستوطنات في
قطاع غزه ايضا عادت الى العمل اي الحديث
ان الحياه الطبيعيه بشكل عام في قطاع في
قطاع غزه وايضا في مستوطنات الغلاف تعود
به الى الحياه الطبيعيه ولكن نعلم بان
الاضرار في اسرائيل وفي المستوطنات كانت
اقل بكثير من قطاع غزه لذلك العوده الى
الحياه الطبيعيه سوف يكون اسهل فقط الخروج
من الملاجئ وايضا عوده اعداد كبيره من
المستوطنين الى مستوطنات الغلاف اشكرك
جزيل الشكر من حدود القطاع غزه مراسله
العربيه لناكل غسي
اذا بعد ساعات من دخول اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار حيز التنفيذ افدت وسائل اعلام
فلسطينيه باصابه شاب برصاص القوات
الاسرائيليه بعد اقتحام البلده القديمه في
مدينه نابلس وزاره الصحه قالت ان الشابه
اصيب خلال المواجهات التي اندلعت عقب
عمليه الاقتحام
عقب عمليه الاقتحام نقل لمستشفى رفيده
الحكومي بمدينه نابلس واسفلت عمليه
الاقتحام ايضا عن اعتقال شابين اخرين
طالبه ازاله الخارجيه الفلسطينيه المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه باصدار مذكره جلب وتوقيف
بحق وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار
جاء ذلك بعد تصريحات ادلى بها تعليقا على
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه ضد حركه
الجهاد في غزه حيث دعا الى شني عمليه اخرى
في الضفه الغربيه واستخدام اسلوب القتل
المستهدف ضد بعض القاده بحسب صحيفه تايمز
اوف اسرائيل
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها ايضا بعد الفاصل من
فرنسا الفارون من حرب السودان يعيشون تحت
هول الصدمه والقلق
في محادثات جده لبحث ايصال المساعدات
الاشتباكات تتجدد في الخرطوم وسط تحليق
مكثف للمقاتلات
لاول مره منذ الحرب في برلين والمانيا
تستبق الزياره بحزمه مساعدات بثلاثه
مليارات دولار
حياكم الله من جديد تجددت الاشتباكات
بالخرطوم بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع حيث افاد مراسل العربيه بان
اشتباكات عنيفه تركزت في ام درمان ووسط
الخرطوم واضاف المراسل ان الطيران الحربي
واصل التحليق في العاصمه الخرطوم مشيرا
الى تجدد الاشتباكات المسلحه والتي تفاقم
من معاناه المعاناه الانسانيه للسودانيين
في تلك المناطق
تجدد الاشتباكات تزامن مع استئناف طرفي
الصراع اليوم المحادثات في جده بشان كيفيه
تنفيذ خطه ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه وفق
ما كشفت عنه وكاله رويترز نقلا عن مسؤول
دبلوماسي سعودي المسؤول اوضح ان المحادثات
تركز على سحب القوات من المناطق المدنيه
بالاضافه الى فتح ممرات امنه واخلاء
المناطق المدنيه
وسيبقى طرفاء الصراع في جده لبدء المرحله
التاليه من المفاوضات بعد الاتفاق الذي
توصل له
طرف هذه الازمه بشان حمايه المدنيين
وهذه اذن صور مباشره مشاهدينا لوصول
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لاحد لجان
الاقتراع في اسطنبول كما نشاهد امامنا اذا
وصل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الى
احداب مراكز
الاقتراع ايضا الموجوده في اسطنبول ياتي
هذا بعد ان وصل كمال كالجدار اوغلو الى
مركز
الى مركز الانتخابي واحد الرجال للادلاء
بصوت يصل الان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان للادلائي بصوته ايضا كذلك في هذه
الانتخابات وفي احدى مراكز الاقتراع
باسطنبول اذا وصل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان تابعناه منذ الامس وهو طبعا قد
بدا برمجه
الانتخابي وكذلك ايضا اجتمع بمنا
صريه وتحدث عن مستقبل تركيا يتحدث عن خطط
لمعالجه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه كذلك الحاليه
ركز ايضا على السياسه الداخليه الاقتصاديه
بشكل
خاص كذلك ايضا كان قد تحدث في تجمعاته
الانتخابيه عن السياسه الخارجيه لتركيا
الان يصل مرشح تحالف الشعب
رئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان الى احدى
مراكز الاقتراع باسطنبول ياتي هذا بعد ان
وصل كمال كلجدار اوكلو الى احدى مراكز
الاقتراع في العاصمه التركيه انقره ادلى
بصوته تحدث ايضا بعد ذلك بانه اشتاق الى
الديمقراطيه والى ربيع الحريات في تركيا
يصل الان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
مرشح تحالف الشعب للادلاء بصوته في احدى
مراكز الاقتراع باسطنبول وكما نشاهد ياخذ
بعض ربما الصور امامنا في هذا المركز مركز
الاقتراعي يتحدث كذلك مع الموجودين في هذا
المركز انتخابات اذا تركيا توصف بانها
الانتخابات ربما الاقوى الاشد في التنافس
في تركيا منذ عقود وبانها تاتي في توقيت
صعب مهم وحساس دقيق للغايه ايضا على
المستوى السياسي على المستوى الاقتصادي
ايضا كذلك وحتى على المستوى الاجتماعي
داخل تركيا برفقته طبعا
زوجته كما نشاهد الان في هذه الصور
وابنائه ايضا وصلوا معه الى احدى مراكز
الاقتراع في اسطنبول هذه الانتخابات التي
سبقتها ربما استطلاعات للراي عبرت بشكل او
اخر كما ينقل بعض المحللين والمتابعين
ايضا
بان شعبيه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
اهتزت بعد جائحه كورونا بعد ايضا الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه المتردي وكذلك ايضا حتى ربما
بعدما حدث من زلزال تركيا وسوريا الزلزال
الذي ضرب الاجزاء الجنوبيه من تركيا
والتعامل ايضا كذلك الحكومه التركيه مع
تبعات هذا الزلزال استطلاعات الرئيس اشارت
ايضا الى تقدم طفيف لكمال كالجدار اوغلو
وايضا هناك بعض الاستطلاعات اظهرت بان
الرئيس التركي الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
يتقدم في هذه
ربما الانتخابات لكن ايضا على الجهه
الاخرى هناك بعض استطلاعات الراي التي
اشارت الى تقدم منافسه الرئيسي في هذه
الانتخابات مرشح تحالف الامه كمال كلجدار
اوغلو ايضا الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الذي
استلم دفه السلطه في تركيا منذ عام 2003
هو اول رئيس منتخب مباشره عام 2014 فتره
حكم الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان شهدت
محاوله انقلاب فاشله عام 2016 حزبه تمكن
من الفوز باستفتاء عام
2017 فرض عددا من التعديلات الدستوريه
التركيه تحولت مع الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان الى
النظام الرئاسي من النظام البرلماني الى
نظام الرئاسي الان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان يتوجه اذا مشاهدينا للادلاء بصوته
في هذا المركز مركز مركز الاختراع
بالعاصمه او مركز الاختراع عفوا باسطنبول
سبقه كمال كلجدار اوغلو الذي ادلى بصوته
في العاصمه التركيه انقره بعض من يتواجدون
في هذا المركز يلتقطون الصور مع الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان مناصري اردوغان
اذا
ياخذون هذه الصور التذكاريه مع الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اذا كان قد قدم
وعودا اقتصاديا عده تستهدف الشباب
التضخم اذن كذلك الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان والذي كما ذكرنا يدخل هذه
الانتخابات التي تعتبر الاشد
تنافسا منذ السنوات هذه الانتخابات التي
يعني يعبر عنها بانها ربما
تغير الشكل السياسه الخارجيه بالنسبه
لتركيا في تعاملها مع الازمات التي تتعلق
تحديدا بحلف الناتو كان هناك حديث عن تدخل
في هذه الانتخابات ايضا كذلك من قبل روسيا
على سبيل المثال لكن الكرمل النفى هذا
التدخل كمال كالجدار اوغلو كان قد اتهم
حزب العداله والتنميه مشاهدينا بان روسيا
تتدخل
لنصرته في هذه الانتخابات لكن الكرملين
علقنا فكل هذه
اتهامات وصفات اتهامات اردوغان اذا يدري
بصوته الان في احدى مراكز الاقتراع
باسطنبول كما ذكرنا هو الرئيس التركي الذي
استلم دفه السلطه منذ عام 2003 اي قبل
عقدين من الان هو اول رئيس انتخب بشكل
مباشر عام 2014 فتره حكمه شهدت محاوله
انقلاب فاشله عام 2016 حزبه تمكن من الفوز
حزب العداله والتنميه باستفتاء عام 2017
وفرض عددا من التعديلات الدستوريه تركيا
تحولت في عهده من النظام البرلماني الى
الرئاسي ايضا يسعى لولايه الرئاسيه
الثالثه كما ذكرنا بعد ان حكم لمده عقدين
من الزمن قدم وعودا اقتصاديه عده تستهدف
الشباب تستهدف التضخم الان يدخل للادلاء
بصوته في احدى مراكز الاقتراع باسطنبول
كما نشاهد هو دخل الى هذه الغرفه غرفه
الاقتراع الرئيس الحالي
ومرشح تحالف الشعب الرئيس التركي الحالي
رجب طيب اردوغان اذا وصل امامنا للادلاء
بصوته في هذه الانتخابات التي يتنافس كما
ذكرنا قبل قليل فيها مع مرشح تحالف الامه
كمال كالجدار اوغلو ومرشح تحالف الاجداد
سنان اوغان في هذه الانتخابات التي ستكون
مصيريه وحافله اذن انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه مراكز الاقتراع كما ذكرنا فتحت
ابوابها منذ صباح اليوم وسط اجراءات امنيه
اجراءات ايضا كذلك مشدده بلغ عدد الناخبين
المسجلين في هذه الانتخابات حتى هذه
اللحظه اكثر من 64 مليون ناخب كما تم وضعه
ما يقرب من
الف صندوق اقتراع في البلاد وخارجها اذا
توجه ودخل هذه الغرفه ومن خلف الستار اذا
يدلي بصوته الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في هذه الصور المباشره امامنا كما
ذكرنا رفقه اسرته ايضا التي وصلت معه الى
هذه او الى هذه الغرفه الى هذا المركز
ايضا مركز الاقتراع باسطنبول الصراع
الرئيسي مشاهدينا كما جاءت التوقعات وصلت
الرئيس ستكون فعلا بين الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان وايضا كذلك مرشح المعارضه
ككلجدار اوغلو بتظهر استطلاعات الراي
تقدما بفارق ضئيل لكمال كيلجار اوغلو
المنافس الرئيسي لاردوغان في هذه
الانتخابات المدن الرئيسيه التركيه تشهد
تعزيزات امنيه
فحتى يتمكن الناخبون من ممارسه حقهم في
التصويت بامان هناك انتشار لاكثر من 600
الف عنصر امن في المدن التركيه لتامين هذه
الانتخابات والسير هذه الانتخابات في
الرابع عشر من مايو اليوم وهو اليوم
الحاسم اليوم المصيري الذي انتظرته
تركيا اذا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
وصل برفقه اسرته الى هذا المركز مركز
الاقتراع باسطنبول بانتظار طبعا ان يخرج
من هذه الغرفه امامنا بعد ان يدلي بصوته
الرئيس الحالي ونعيد التذكير اذا مشاهدينا
بانه استلم دفه السلطه او دفه السلطه عام
2003 هو اول رئيس انتخب بشكل مباشر
عام 2014 شهدت فتره حكمه عددا طبعا من
الاحداث على
المستويات الداخليه الامنيه في تركيا ايضا
الازمه ربما التي كانت يعني قد خلفتها
محاوله الانقلاب الفاشله عام 2016 الازمه
بين الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان وكذلك
ايضا المعارضه هناك اقبال كبير على هذه
الانتخابات كما تابعنا منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى وكما يعني ينظر اليها بعض
المراقبين او المتابعين بانها مقارنه
بالانتخابات السابقه تعتبر
الاعداد التي وصلت الى هذه
المراكز مراكز الاقتراع اعداد كبيره جدا
مقارنه بالانتخابات الماضيه من المتوقع ان
تشهد هذه الانتخابات اكبر نسبه مشاركه
للمنتخبين في تاريخ تركيا كما تشير بعض
استطلاعات الراي اذا خرج الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان من الغرفه غرفه الاقتراب
بعد ان ادلى بصوتها ويدلي بصوته الان كما
نشاهد امامنا في هذه الصور اذا كما ذكرنا
المعارضه التركيه تحلم بالفوز في هذه
الانتخابات
وبان تقصي اردوغان وتهزمه في هذه
الانتخابات بعد 20 عاما من حكم تركيا
اذا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ادلى
بصوته كما ذكرنا في احدى مراكز الاقتراع
باسطنبول
وكما ذكرنا قبل قليل بان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اذا مشاهدينا يعيشوا انتخابات
حاسمه ايام حاسمه ايضا كذلك استطلاعات
الراي ربما تشير الى الترجيح الكفه
لكمال كلجدار اوغلو ذكر في وقت سابق رجب
طيب اردوغان بانه سيقبل بنتيجه هذه
الانتخابات ايا كانت حتى وان كان قد خسر
هذه الانتخابات ايضا فانه سيقبل الهزيمه
في هذه الانتخابات اذا وصل وصوت ايضا في
هذا المركز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
سبقه ايضا مرشح المعارضه كذلك كمال
كالجدار ربما هناك تصريح للرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان بعد ان ادلى بصوته نستمع
الى هذا التصريح ثم نعود
ان شاء الله
ما هي تصريحتكم حول ذلك طبعا بعد التصويت
الاهم ربما ما عليه ان اقوله هو انه يوم
ديمقراطي منذ صباح اليوم بدات عمليه
الاقتراع وطبعا حسب
المستجده تحصلت عليها من وزير الداخليه
التركي انه لا توجد اي مشاكل في عموم
البلاد وعمليه التصويت جاريه الى حد الان
طبعا مناطق الزلازل ايضا كما تعلمون تحت
العمليات الانتخابات
والمواطنين هناك
يقوم بادلاء بقصتهم طبعا لا توجد اي مشاكل
هناك ايضا اتمنى واعمل ان
تكون النتيجه خيرا
للبلاد ووسيله تخيل للبلاد الديمقراطيه في
البلاد اسال الله التوفيق
تبعنا هذا التصريح للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان معه نختم هذه النشره شكرا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات